ça fait des années qu'on n'a pas vu de
telle foule dans les rues de varsovie et
autres grandes villes du pays
semaine après semaine des milliers de
polonais protestent contre les
politiques de leur nouveau gouvernement
pourtant démocratiquement élu on se
dirige vers une dictature dit cet homme
la vice-présidente du code comité de
défense de la démocratie né en décembre
assure que les manifestations vont
continuer faut dire que le gouvernement
du parti paix et justice n'y va pas avec
le dos de la cuillère élu en octobre
avec 37% des voix
cette formation conservatrice populiste
catholique et anti européenne ne perd
pas une minute
les changements au tribunal
constitutionnel ont été votées entre
noël et jour de l'an à 4 heures du matin
quelques jours plus tard la loi sur les
médias qui change les télévisions et
radios publiques en chaîne d'état a été
adoptée à toute vitesse
dorénavant c'est le gouvernement qui en
nommera les dirigeants une grande purge
est déjà en cours sept analystes
déplorent que ces mesures n'est jamais
été abordé en campagne électorale s'il
serait allé au pouvoir avec un programme
qui dit on va ignorer la constitution et
faire ce que nous pensons et nécessaire
pour le bien être de la nation
et s'il aurait gagné les élections
j'aurai je serai toujours contre il
serait toujours dans la rue mais au
moins les choses au clair
ils n'ont pas le mandat pour démolir
l'état ils n'ont pas le mandat pour
violer la constitution
on nous indique que les règles de base
du tribunal constitutionnel ne sont pas
respectés et ceci est très grave
vice président de la commission
européenne la commission inquiètes des
dérives polonaise décide de lancer une
enquête préliminaire sur les attaques à
l'état de droit en pologne une première
il n'en fallait pas plus pour que
l'homme fort de la pologne voit rouge
jaroslaw kaczinsky à la tête du parti
paix justice
il est le frère jumeau du président mort
tragiquement il ya cinq ans en russie
dans l'accident d'avion qui a décimé le
gouvernement polonais connu pour ses
coups de gueule contre bruxelles bonne
et moscou il fulmine à l'idée de voir
l'union européenne se mêler des affaires
polonaise
il ne manque pas d'appui comme l'éditeur
de ce magazine qui vient de publier à la
une un pastiche d'une photo des années
hitler et ses généraux sont remplacés
par anouk et la merkel et les
responsables européens
ils veulent à nouveau assujettir la
pologne peut-on y lire
si ce soit auraient été les américains
ou même les canadiens à nous poser des
questions on pourrait les ignorer on
peut pas ignorer les européens nous
sommes l'europe
mais alexandra cette décision de lancer
cette enquête
est ce que c'est vraiment sérieux à quoi
ça pourrait aboutir au fond et des
étapes c'est nous qui sont prévus il ya
une évaluation des recommandations et
suivi des recommandations mais la
véritable mesure qui pourrait faire un
peu mal c'est la suspension du droit de
vote une statue suspentes de pays
suspendus c'est prévu dans l'est dans
les traités et mais c'est considéré
comme l'armé nucléaire ça jamais été
utilisé ça ne le sera probablement pas
parce qu'on demande
ça demande des quatre cinquièmes des
votants 4 5e des pays européens
devraient voter pour cette mesure pour
que la pologne soit puni en fait il ya
que l'armé économique qui pourrait
vraiment content et la pologne reçoit
énormément de l'argent c'est le pays qui
reçoit le plus d'argent de l'union
européenne 115 milliards de dollars
d'ici 2020 alors si on suspendait ses
paiements la la ça ferait très mal mais
c'est pas prévu par le statut et c'est
pas le seul pays en fait à être tombés
dans cette dérive autoritaire on veut
penser à la hongrie par exemple
oui la hongrie vous avérée
depuis 2010 viktor orban s'est engagé un
peu dans la même voie dans laquelle la
pologne s'engage maintenant avec les
mets du contrôle des médias contrôle du
tribunal constitutionnel et c'est un peu
ça qu'on veut éviter avec la pologne
parce qu'avec la hongrie on n'a pas
réagi de façon assez sérieuse alors la
pologne est un pays bien sûr beaucoup
plus grand important ou sept fois plus
grand en terme de population que la
hongrie on veut éviter ça mais les
autorités ne semblent pas l'entendre de
de la même façon et aujourd'hui la
première miss a déjà dit que l'europe
n'a rien à dire dans les affaires
polonaise alors on vrai revers